The best way to learn about classical conditioning is by starting with its
discovery by Ivan Pavlov, who was looking at digestion in dogs. Actually Pavlov
learned about classical conditioning by accident. Here's what happened. Pavlov
was actually a physiologist who was interested in studying digestion, and he
used dogs to do so. Every day he would come into his laboratory, put a little
bit of meat powder on the dog's tongue, and the dog would automatically
salivate, and Pavlov collected that salivation and analyzed it. However, one
day when Pavlov came into the lab, he saw that the dog salivated automatically,
even though it didn't have any meat powder. Pavlov wondered if perhaps he could
be the reason the dog was salivating, and it turns out he was correct.